today's video has been made possible by
one dream
if you're in need of an awesome online
learning platform then stick around
until the end to find out more
oh
oh
it is new year's eve the knights of king
arthur's court enjoy the christmas
festivities with a grand
feast they exchange gifts with one
another
and at the request of arthur they share
stories of adventure
all of a sudden the doors are forced
open and a mysterious figure rides down
the hall
before them is an enormous man on a
green horse
with green skin green hair
and a green axe he dismounts holding his
axe in one hand
and a branch of holly in the other
naturally this intrusion is not taken
lightly
and the knights of arthur draw their
weapons the green knight
before them laughs this off claiming he
has not come
looking for a fight even if that was the
case
no man in this room would even come
close to presenting a challenge for him
instead he wishes to share in the
festivities with a game
the rules to this game are fairly simple
anyone who is brave enough may take
their weapon and strike him as hard as
they desire
whoever accepts this challenge will get
to keep his splendid
axe the only condition the green knight
sets
is that they will meet again in one year
and one
day and he will return the blow
a game like this would cause some
hesitation why would anyone want to play
a game that would result in certain
death
what is the catch here the knights
remained
weary but king arthur was not one to shy
away from a challenge
and so he was ready to accept however
arthur's nephew and the youngest of all
the knights stepped forward
sagar wayne accepted this challenge on
behalf of arthur
eager to prove himself worthy the green
knight took no exception to this
he lent over and presented his neck
almost
instructing gawain where to strike
gawain took his blade and in one swift
strike
beheaded the green knight the young
knight was given the prestige and
recognition he desired and our story
ends here at least that's what may have
happened if the green knight was an
ordinary man
he neither flinched nor fell despite
being decapitated
instead he dropped his axe walked over
to his severed head
picked it up and faced the king and
queen
in one year and one day we shall meet
again at the green chapel and i shall
return the blow sir gawain
he reminded the young knight before
riding off
his sinister laugh echoing through the
hall
arthur assured his terrified wife that
this was merely a light-hearted game
to ease her concerns but gawain didn't
seem so convinced
he took the acts as a trophy but also as
a reminder of his promise to the green
knight
as the year went by gawain continued his
duties and took part in several
adventures
paying little notice to what appeared to
be his impending
death eventually the day drew close
and gawain set off to meet the green
knight in the green chapel
on his way he came across a magnificent
castle
and in need of rest he decided to enter
the lord of the castle and his beautiful
wife were overjoyed to have such an
esteemed
guest gawain only planned on a short
rest
but the lord insisted he enjoyed their
hospitality until he was fully rested
and ready to continue his journey
as the green chapel was less than a few
miles away
given what was waiting for him at the
green chapel he decided to accept the
lord's offer
the only other person of note in the
castle was an old hag
who gawain assumed must have been of
some importance
by the amount of respect she was given
by the servants
and the lord himself the lord was a
rather big fan of hunting
and so he made gawain a proposal
every day the lord went out hunting he
would give gawain what he
caught on the condition that gawain
would give him
whatever he had gained during the day
he accepted the lord's challenge and
when he set out for his daily hunt
gawain was left to explore the castle
grounds and rest
however his day would possess its own
challenges
the lord's wife began with some subtle
flirtation
and so in order to avoid an
uncomfortable situation
gawain retreated to his chambers
unfortunately she followed
and continued her seduction trying his
best to not offend his hostess but also
respects his host
he allowed the lord's wife a single kiss
when the lord returned he presented
gawain with a deer
and in return he was given a kiss but
gawain didn't mention
where the kiss came from the next day
the lord set out for his hunt
once again and once again gawain
rejected the advances from his wife
this time he was given two kisses
the lord returned with a boar for gawain
and in exchange he was given
two kisses and again gawain didn't tell
him
where they came from the third day
begins with the lord
setting off for his hunt however when
gawain rejects the advances of his
hostess this time
she gives him a golden ring to remember
her by
even this is rejected by gawain but she
insists that he accepts her sash
a wonderful green and gold sash that had
been enchanted to protect the wearer
from
any physical harm this item gawain
accepted
after all there was a giant green knight
eager to decapitate him
gawain is then given three kisses and is
made to promise he will keep the gift a
secret from her husband when the lord
returns he presents gawain with a fox
this time
and in exchange he's given three kisses
but gawain fails to mention the sash
that was given to him
the next morning is the day gawain must
travel to the green
chapel he ties the sash around his belt
at least now there is a chance he may
survive the encounter
when he arrives at the chapel the green
knight is already there
sharpening his axe gawain hesitantly
walks over
and as part of their deal presents his
neck as he prepares to receive his blow
the knight pulls back his axe and swings
but stops just
short as gawain flinches the green
knight
laughs telling gawain he thought the
knights of arthur feared
nothing the second time the green knight
pulls back his axe and swings gawain
bites down
and does not flinch the blow he received
most definitely did not match the one
given
strangely gawain was angry at the green
knights for holding back
and so he berated the knight until he
did strike him at full
force luckily for gawain the sash given
to him appeared to have worked
and the strike only left behind a small
wound
gawain prepared to leave believing the
night's game was over
but he towered over him laughing and
when gawain challenged him
he revealed himself as lord bertilak
the exact same lord of the castle gawain
had been a guest of
he was transformed into the green knight
through the use of
magic the old woman he noticed earlier
was actually the sorceress morgan the
fae in disguise
she had planned the entire game as a way
of testing the honor of the knights of
arthur
the axe would have never caused gawain
any harm
but because he failed to present
bertilak with the sash his wife had
given him
the scar from the third strike would be
ever present
a mark of his dishonesty gawain kneeled
in shame for his deceit
but the green knight laughed and told
him to stand
reminding him to not hold himself to
such unrealistic standards
the fact he honored his end of the
bargain was enough for the green knight
to call him the most
blameless night in all the land
gawain returned to camelot wearing the
sash
a symbol of his failure to keep his
promise
in honor of gawain's adventure the
knights agreed to wear a
green sash a reminder to always be
honest the story of sir wayne and the
green knight is classed as a shiverick
romance
it was written towards the end of the
14th century and we don't know who the
author was
the poem itself also had no title until
several centuries later
surprisingly at the time it was written
it was received very poorly
or as today it's a highly revered story
that's been studied and adapted in
several forms
one of the most famous examples being a
translation of the poem by
none other than tolkien himself what
inspired me to go back over this story
and make this video
was the modern film adaptation that is
scheduled to be released around
august of this year which is titled the
green
knight watching the trailer i like the
design of the green knight himself
but given hollywood's track record when
it comes to adapting classic stories
i'm about as optimistic as a man about
to be beheaded by a
giant green knight but i'd love to be
surprised
as we mentioned earlier this video has
been sponsored by one dream
you may have heard me talk about the
great courses plus in the past
in order to create a bigger better and
more
interactive educational experience
they've teamed up to create
one dream you can still find all the
same great courses plus
content but now there's even more so if
you'd like to learn more about arthurian
law i'd recommend
king arthur history and legends
now when i checked out the one dream
collection i found all sorts of
tutorials how to's
documentaries and a range of short and
long form content designed to inform and
entertain wandering minds normally i'd
gravitate towards space and wildlife
but this time i found myself watching
the everyday guide to beer
and i don't even really drink beer did i
learn about the different flavor
profiles and how to pair beer with
specific meals
yes i'm not sure when i'd ever use this
information but i am now a
certified beer connoisseur i did also
learn that it was an accidental creation
that came from making bread in ancient
samaria
people used to drink beer out of giant
communal jars using straws and if you
were rich enough you'd have a golden
straw
so there is your mind-blowing and
totally necessary fact of the day
if you'd also like answers to questions
you never knew needed asking
then visit wandream.com mythology
to start your free trial today
as always i've been your host mythology
and fiction explained
[Music]
you